several texas counties are getting ready
to declare an invasion at the southern
border hoping to trigger part of the u.s
constitution that makes the federal
government responsible for protecting
states against invasions this comes as
the united nations just labeled the u.s
mexican border as the deadliest crossing
in the entire world after 53 migrants
were found dead last week in a tractor
trailer in san antonio texas and as the
border crisis only worsens the biden
administration doesn't seem to be taking
any responsibility for it instead
blaming a host of other things including
climate change watch
the migration that is occurring
throughout the hemisphere is reflective
of the economic downturn increase in
violence throughout the region the
the result of the covet 19 pandemic the
results of climate change
david the bottom line is these local and
state governments they feel abandoned by
the federal government val verde county
commissioner robert nettleton he said at
the end of the day the federal
government is not doing its job and
these local communities need to come up
with a solution but what what gets me
more than anything else is the
inhumanity of the whole thing of course
mentioned the 53 people that were killed
imagine opening a trailer truck and
seeing 53 dead bodies that you know the
the trump administration was criticized
by biden for being inhumane for having
an inhumane border crossing if you get
the designation of being the number one
dangerous lethal border crossing in the
world
1238 migration deaths in 2021 i know
that's just a number and and statistics
are horrible in the way they deal with
human beings but the inhumanity of this
policy far exceeds any inhumanity from
previous administrations i mean this it
has a record just in terms of pure
numbers of people who are suffering and
dying as a result of these policies
that's right harris and these are people
1.7 million encounters i know as you say
statistics are hard for us to appreciate
but each one is a life with a family and
a story and where's our vice president
who's the star of the southern border
where is any type of actual compassion
from the government that claims their
policies are compassionate well and i
was just going to say when you talk with
people in congress who've gone down your
husband has gone down sean duffy has as
a congressperson
when you talk to andy biggs of of
arizona when you talk to the attorneys
general from these different border
states and even far beyond because
fentanyl makes us all a border state now
so it's been said so it is true
but when you talk to those people you
get the humanity
because they will tell you of the little
ones that are being pulled out of the
water or the rio grande inches from a
life taken that i mean they're they're
actually there which is why you need the
bully pulpit of the president and the
the borders are are we even still
calling her that i mean i feel like i
think a lot of times
not actually true
but i mean if if you put their bully
pulpit there and they're great
storytellers that have to be right
because they all gave speeches
so if they could shine a light on this
and see for themselves maybe they could
find some answers but you know i guess
if you don't see it you don't have to do
anything about it right and we've talked
about that the abject failure on the
part of this administration to
acknowledge the catastrophe at the
southern border the cruel the cruelty of
their policies and yet they've been
tasked with securing it instead kamala
hara says well i'm going to focus on
climate change and root causes so her
title feels false but it's still her
title
yeah i mean listen
the humanity the lack of compassion
you're so right david they said that
their
policies were compassionate those people
were cooked alive and by the way those
numbers don't actually
say what happens to there's many people
who die on the board
in the desert that we never hear of
there are children who are being sex
trafficked we don't know anything about
that people thousands thousands and so
this is a lack of compassion i look at
joe biden and i say you know we were
talking about chivalry in the break with
your little one and a half year old talk
about lack of chivalry as a you're the
father of the country as the president
you have no care for not just the
migrants but the people that you
represent on those border states who
feel so abandoned that they say we're
being invaded and you don't care that's
right and kaylee let's go back to that
u.n report you have some additional
information about that yeah the author
of the report said that the number of
deaths at the border is worse than any
prior year even pre-covered okay so that
means the 2021 numbers are worse than
any prior year well what happened in
2021 this guy named president joe biden
took over and rolled back every single
trump policy this this didn't happen in
a vacuum this happened when you roll
back remain in mexico when you strip
away title 42 when you incentivize
people to come uh and to your point
rachel it's a very good point about the
number of deaths that are not counted in
this what about in the darien gap that's
this treacherous territory in panama
that migrants come through before they
even make it to mexico and a lot of them
perish in that jungle so this number is
far higher in 2021 about double what it
was the year prior that's because of a
guy named joe biden who is now the
president can i just say one other thing
commander-in-chief is one of his titles
as well and the border patrol agents are
going through misery and hell as well
and a lot of them are dying as well as a
result of not getting the support they
need i would just quickly say those
numbers were before we got to this point
so what are we on track for for 2022
right right because the last glimmer of
hope was the remaining mexico policy
which now given the decision coming out
of the supreme court means it will be
just another surge i don't see an end to
me it feels hopeless and that's why
these states are taking it upon
themselves to declare an invasion saying
we have nothing else left to do it is up
to us because the federal government is
totally failing
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight